[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby versez y réaliser une très belle
opération ce week end dans le
championnat de division honneur les
hommes de la cité royale se sont imposés
contre le leader en manque mais ce
dimanche cette victoire leur permet de
rester dans la course à la montée plus
de détails à suivre
cyclisme changement la tête de la
fédération française michel cailliau est
le nouveau président de la ffc depuis ce
samedi seul candidat l'homme de 50 ans
succède à david lappartient en poste
depuis 2009 pour les pôles et un nid
vinoy jean michel richefort du club de
vélizy 78 a été nommé au bureau exécutif
baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux joueront cette saison en
première division nous les avons
rencontrés à moins de trois semaines du
début du championnat
vous entendrez dans cette édition le
coach de l'équipe va rodolphe le meur en
groupant à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence ce magazine par la belle
victoire du rugby-club de versailles sur
son teint contre man clim et deux
équipes au coude à coude pour la montée
en fédérale 3 en fin de saison
les versaillais l'ont emporté à 22 à 13
dans un match asus à suspense comptant
pour la 15e journée du championnat
des images sont signés à nicolas landry
une performance qui devrait compter à la
fin du championnat les versets et se
sont offert ce dimanche devant leur
bouillant stade de porchefontaine le
leader menthe lit mais sur le terrain
cette dixième victoire de la saison en
division honneur a été longue à se
dessiner
les joueurs de la cité royale ne
menaient que 14 13 à la 50e minute et
versez y ont ensuite accéléré dans le
dernier quart d'heure pour remporter la
victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on devait de gagner chose faite 22 13
ça a été compliqué ils ont mis du rythme
de vendre a bien répondu
on marque trois beaux essais donc voilà
l'important c'est la victoire alors
l'histoire des bonus à la dernière
seconde
donc voilà on est content maintenant il
nous reste trois matches au matap à
faire pour remonter dès cette saison
fédérale 3 les versets y est deuxième du
championnat à l'issue de cette 15e
journée devront réaliser une série de
trois victoires contre vitry vincennes
et bagneux défaite interdite les quatre
premiers du classement se tiennent en
quatre points
c'est une poule très serrée on n'avait
aucun match facile à gagner à domicile
comme à l'extérieur c'est dur l'objectif
de toute façon c'est je les dis enfin
c'est les phases finales
voilà on se pose pas trop de questions
en fait c'est gagner les matchs après
matchs après matchs et si on gagne ce
qui nous reste les trois derniers on n'y
pense pas on y pense mais le fait
d'avoir pris 20 points il ya quinze
jours à gretz tournan à g t au ça nous a
remis un peu les pieds sur terre et pour
l'instant on va aller chercher les
phases finales et c'est après on verra
le sprint final débutera le dimanche 19
mars les versaillais se déplaceront sur
le terrain de vitry avant-dernier de
division honneur
on continue par du rugby rien n'arrête
le sky cette saison dans le championnat
de promotion d'honneur l'équipe senior
coachée par thomas payen vient
d'engranger dimanche sur son terrain sa
12e victoire en 14 matchs contre noisy
le sec
le score est sans appel 41 à 8 au
classement les saint quentinois s'envole
et compte 10 points d'avancé sur le 2e
chilly mazarin
en cas de victoire à domicile
dimanche prochain à 15 heures contre
saint-andré verger le sky montera en
honneur en ballons joués à ce week-end
en prénationale à masculine lourde
défaite pour verser dans son gymnase
mont boron les joueurs d'alexandre
taillefer se sont inclinés 40 à 23
contre eux et athlétique club
de son côté c'est un plaisir s'est
imposée à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
val de seine au classement les plaisirs
oies sont toujours premier avec un point
d'avancé sur le deuxième fb 2ème
versailles dans le ventre mou à la
sixième place sur 12 équipes engagées en
cyclisme changement à la tête de la
fédération française michel à cailhau
élu nouveau président de la ffc depuis
ce samedi seul candidat l'homme de 50
ans a été élu avec près de 98% des
suffrages et succède à david lappartient
en poste depuis 2009 pour les pôles et
un yvelinois jean michel richefort du
club de vélizy 78
il a été nommé au bureau exécutif
l'homme qui a passé 24 heures sur son
vélo à l'occasion du téléthon 2015 sur
la piste du vélodrome nous confie ses
projets pour le cyclisme français
cette nouvelle responsabilité donc va
m'amener à développer et puis avec le
porte parole de ce projet dont les axes
principaux sont d'améliorer les
conditions d'accueil des licenciés parce
qu'il est indispensable d'élargir cette
pyramide élargie dans cette pyramide et
licenciés mais aussi de teleclub
d'outils fédéraux moderne et bien sûr
donner un élan au projet sportif de haut
niveau on reste dans le monde du
cyclisme le vélodrome national proposé
pour la deuxième année consécutive un
évènement 100% filles baptisée elle à
vélo un moyen pour les participants de
passer une soirée entre amis mais aussi
d'être sensibilisés à la pratique du
cyclisme bien-être et baptêmes de piste
étaient au programme retour sur son
rendez vous avec mélanie poké
elle les premiers gestes sont hésitants
mais le staff de la fédération française
de cyclisme produits des conseils pour
sa deuxième édition elle à vélo invité à
nouveau les femmes au vélodrome c'est
une super idée ça permet de se retrouver
entre filles passaient aussi un bon
moment c'est une belle façon de célébrer
la journée de la femme
et puis on a fait des jolies découvertes
notamment le vélo smoothie qu'on a
trouvé très sympa d'ailleurs on fait
déjà du vélo un peu de bmx de vtt là
c'était l'occasion de faire un baptême
piste j'avais jamais fait baptême donc
que nathalie simon ancienne championne
de planche à voile et animatrice télé à
elle même testé génial chez monter
jusqu'aux
au dessus du bleu en haut à la presse
qu'en haut et je pensais vraiment pas
quand je les ai vus au tout début je
disais mais j'aime y arriver c'est
impossible tape en apnée et vinci et je
suis très très très contente soirée
entre filles mais avec un but bien
précis montré que le cyclisme se
conjugue aussi au féminin
c'est la mission que s'est donnée la
fédération actuellement seulement 10 %
des licenciés sont des femmes
on voit que le troisième sport pratiqué
par les femmes à 33% si le cyclisme va
c'est le vélo sens large du terme
toutes les pratiques vtt route ou
d'autres doc est un potentiel énorme en
matière de développement et je pense que
on va pouvoir monter à 25 % de licenciés
dame au sein de la fédération
c'est une ambition et pour ça on s'est
donné des moyens des outils pour que nos
clubs sont aussi sensibilisés à
l'ensemble des pratiques un kit
pédagogique sera proposé au club dès le
mois de juin pour donner des ailes aux
vélos on clôture cette large page
cyclisme par la 25e édition de l'agent
massines une conférence de presse était
organisée ce jeudi pour présenter cette
randonnée en vtt qui se tiendra les 29
et 30 avril à saint rémy les chevreuse
plus de 3500 cyclistes sont attendus
pour cet événement l'un des
organisateurs jean baptiste du fourneau
présente les grandes lignes de ce projet
était au micro de camille lambert
on a sept parcours vtt et trois parcours
route
de la difficulté en fête de la famille
jusqu'à l'ultra sportif 120 km vtt sur
un parcours c'est vraiment quelque chose
fait entraîner on a même de l'ultra
ultra sportif avec le trx ou 3g edge
donc là c'est 120 km route le samedi 120
km vtt le dimanche mais on reste aussi
sur des parcours beaucoup plus
accessible avec du 40 km route ou du 40
km avait été on prend à présent la
direction des terrains de baseball les
cougars de montillot bretonne évolueront
cette saison en première division pour
prendre leurs marques avant le début du
championnat programmée le 2 avril les
ignorons 1 recevait ce week-end en match
amical les lions de savigny journée qui
s'est bien déroulée pour les cougars les
joueurs ont remporté leurs deux matchs
ce dimanche pendant la rencontre nous
avons posée à trois questions à
l'entraîneur rodolphe le meur sur la
prochaine saison
on a fait appel à beaucoup de beaucoup
de jeunes surtout c'est vrai que c'est
ça toujours été une autre notre volonté
à montigny cette formule est jeune et
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont venus et qui sont
actuellement en sport études et on veut
les faire jouer c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait appel à eux cette année et on a
aussi quelques recrutements étrangers
qu'on attente mais je pense qu'on veut
on veut surtout voilà être continuer
dans notre esprit de formation
aujourd'hui pour se caler par rapport
aux autres équipes il faut vraiment
avoir un lanceur étrangers ce qui
renforce quand même pas mal de l'équipe
et puis un soir nine fielder faut savoir
qu'un joueur de champ intérieur soit un
catcheur la préparation n'est pas fini
on en est on est en plein dedans là on
conjugue contre séville aujourd'hui on
c'est une des équipes vont à l'encontre
qu'on va rencontrer en championnat la
semaine prochaine au parent à
montpellier faire un autre tournoi avec
des équipes internationales c'est voici
donc et tout l'hiver ça a été refaire
les fondamentaux en gymnase qu'on a la
chance d'avoir un gymnase ici que nous
met à disposition la mairie ça c'est
vraiment important
on peut s'entraîner en hiver parce que
voilà le à l'extérieur c'est impossible
de jouer au baseball donc on a des des
des comores d'énergie menaces qui nous
permet vraiment de pouvoir bien nous
préparer
on va rester modeste c'est vrai qu'on
arrive on est un peu un petit peu le
petit poucet on a déjà une expérience
qui a pas été fabuleuse il ya quelques
années en d1 donc on va y aller
sereinement ce qu'on vise moss et le
milieu de tableau
on voudrait se positionner à la
cinquième sixième place derrière les
grosses écuries comme le mans
montpellier sénart et on aimerait aller
les titiller un peu ses équipes pour
hausse mettant juste en dessous et
pourquoi pas aller gagner un ou deux
matchs chez eux
il faut toujours avoir de l'ambition
surtout à notre niveau
pourquoi pas aller chercher le titre
aujourd'hui vraiment ce qu'on veut c'est
stabilisé il ya des nouveaux nouveaux
joueurs qui arrivent donc il faut qu'on
forme le groupe ça c'est important pour
moi une reconversion professionnelle à
présent l'ancienne nageuse al-soofi le
paranthoën ex coéquipière de laure
manaudou est licencié au cercle des
nageurs de marseille vient de créer son
amie pauline auger d'exporter ou une
place de marché sur internet dédiée au
matériel aux équipements sportifs
pour faire simple c'est un petit peu le
bon coin mais exclusivement réservé au
sport la sportive de 40 ans qui habite à
rocquencourt a décidé de lancer son
affaire dans la zone d'activités promo
paul à montigny le bretonneux
on écoute la sportive sur ce choix
pourquoi pour moi parce que je trouve
que des gens moi je voulais entreprendre
mais je voulais être indépendante donc
donc voilà entreprendre et après je vois
le sport parce que j'ai toujours fait du
sport et que c'est quand même l'élément
je maîtrise le mieux et que je connais
mieux et avec tout le réseau que j'avais
je me suis dit ce serait dommage de ne
pas en profiter
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda on commet cet agenda par de la
boxe le combat avait été repoussée en
début d'année deux jours seulement avant
l'événement après plusieurs semaines
d'incertitude il a désormais une date le
boxeur élan courtois marvin petit de la
team farruggia va affronter le 6 mai
prochain l'espagnol et robes et santana
pour le titre de champion de l'union
européenne dans la catégorie des poids
légers le sportif ibérique est un gros
morceau puisqu'il n'a jamais perdu dans
sa carrière par une petit affiche lui
une seule défaite à son compteur le
combat devrait se dérouler à paris dans
une salle qui reste encore à définir
course à pied à présent si vous êtes un
amateur de trail noter ce rendez vous
dans vos agendas la 10e édition de l'eco
trail de paris est organisée ce samedi
18 mars à 12h15 au départ du vélotour
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le concept 2500 participants venus de
toute la france vont parcourir 80 km en
pleine nature pour tenter de rejoindre
le premier étage de la tour eiffel le
tracé composé à 92% des espaces naturels
passera notamment par les bois des
rousses hier le domaine national de
saint cloud et par la ville de
versailles
après le départ de l'éco très élevé le
tour national de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir le samedi 25 mars
une affiche du championnat de france de
d1 féminine entre brest et ici paris une
première pour l'enceinte yvelinoise la
rencontre s'annonce explosive entre les
deux premières du classement et des
internationale française et norvégienne
si vous êtes intéressés pour voir ce
match ne tardait pas 4000 places ont
déjà été vendues à pour la rencontre
avant de refermer ce journal une triste
nouvelle le sky rugby est en deuil
jean-louis des combes dirigeants dans la
structure correspondant du club ces
dernières années et ex président du ch
est né dans les années 80 est décédé le
dimanche 19 février dans sa 69e année
des suites d'un cancer fulgurant
l'équipe de tv fil 78 présente ses
condoléances à sa famille
c'est la fin de ce magazine très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78
[Musique]